so this was going to be Poppy's song to  set the the adventure in motion and she  goes on a journey to unite the world and  it's very naive it's a really naive  approach this was artistically planned  out by Ruben Perez and he did an  incredible job and also we're really sad  to cut it but yeah I think you know when  we watch the movie again even though we  always want more and more music we found  that we just again needed to move the  story forward in a more quick way and  I'm just so glad that this exists here  for you all to see yes we won't need  them unless these pointy sticks help you  listen or these rocks help you put  yourself in someone else's shoes is this  some kind of jewelry it was actually  kind of cool looking good give me that  we don't even know what's out there  yes we do we're gonna find other trolls  all we have to do is come together and  embrace our sameness  you